[Musica]
e mi date un aiuto quanti di voi
utilizzano integratori alimentari mia
state
iniziate le braccia perfetto
fantastico tanti perché una recente
ricerca dice che praticamente un
italiano su due li utilizza in forma
regolare insomma o occasionalmente
ai tempi di mio nonno e lui era
farmacista anche abbiamo appare a
farmacista anch'io sono farmacista atp
ma non si parlava di integratori ma
sostanzialmente perché non c'era niente
da mangiare quindi non c'era piu niente
da integrare quindi già tanto mangiare
però c'era una cosa che effettivamente
si integrava tutte le domeniche mattina
alle 6 di mattina passavano delle
famiglie che andavano a messa e
lasciavano un flaconcino sul davanzale
della della farmacia e tornavano trovano
flaconcino pieno e quell'ora famoso olio
di ricino che penso che non so quanti di
voi l'avevo mai utilizzato però
all'epoca si integrava ogni domenica una
bella purga una cosa simpatica che mi
rimane di quei tempi ovviamente una
memoria ma quando ero piccolo le vedevo
in farmacia e sono queste sono delle
sanguisughe perché all'epoca anche se
questo ovviamente non è un integratore
ma non è neanche un farmaco è qualcosa
che serve l'organismo quando ci sono si
diceva il sangue pesante una cinese tox
queste venivano attaccate prescritte dal
medico sulla schiena si gonfiavano di
sangue e si lanciava una cosa che
ovviamente oggi non si utilizza più ma
non è vero perché se andate su internet
c'è qualcuno che le vende
e chiaro che i tempi sono cambiati per
fortuna si mangia meglio ci muoviamo
guardiamo un po la nostra salute in
maniera diversa e gli integratori si
utilizzano ovviamente ma durante questo
periodo il covip quali sono stati quelli
più utilizzati ma sicuramente quelli per
sentirsi più forti da un punto di vista
delle difese immunitarie e c'è stato che
questo problema c'è tante persone erano
talmente nervose in tensione ansiose
stressate che non riuscivano a dormire
per cui più 20 per cento di prodotti che
facevano dormire sostanzialmente e poi
perché no all'inizio del comite abbia
mangiato un po male un po tanto a volte
e poi comunque la tensione nervosa ha
dato questi disturbi
il 12 per cento di persone in più che
hanno utilizzato integratori e sono e
che hanno mantenuto
il mercato degli integratori nel mondo
della farmacia nel mondo della
parafarmacia dell'erboristeria perché
comunque sia stato questo consumo
chiaramente consapevole che è un consumo
ripeto che oggi tuttora insomma sta
crescendo da un pezzo che andava sua
doppia cifra oggi sia un po
tranquillizzato ma questi hanno
mantenuto il mercato perché perché oggi
guardiamo al nostro benessere in maniera
un po diversa rispetto a una volta
guardiamo la famiglia guardiamo chi sta
vicino a noi le persone con cui passiamo
più tempo le persone che amiamo quindi
quando pensiamo a star bene pensiamo a
questo sostanzialmente e quindi
l'integratore che di suo
integra quello che io oggi mangio è
qualcosa che utilizzo in momenti
particolari
immaginate un ragazzo che fa sport
immaginatevi una persona anziana che
vuole essere sempre brillante che vuole
avere energia qualcuno che studia
immaginate una donna in gravidanza è un
momento in cui sicuramente sono bisogno
se c'è bisogno di alcune sostanze
l'integratore da questo e se vedete ci
sono tantissimi tantissime piante che ci
danno questa possibilità se vedete
quella bella margherita lek in acea
aumenta bene alle difese immunitarie
quelli in mezzo alla curcuma da una
bellissima spezia che viene utilizzata
come antinfiammatorio
sono tutti diciamo componenti ce ne sono
migliaia al mondo che ci danno questo
tipo di effetti quello che è
interessante è che anche nel campo degli
integratori e interessante l'utilizzo
del prodotto a km zero nel senso che il
chilometro zero non è solo perché non
inquino che ovviamente già una cosa
importante ma perché la materia prima
perde significato tratta perché vengono
attaccate i principi attivi dagli enzimi
e questo vale anche per i prodotti che
utilizziamo nel nostro caso dove una
volta il famoso prima prendevo le piante
le secca lo faceva una tisana che andava
bene all'epoca oggi è una bevanda deve
essere buona piacevole non è quella che
ti cura mediamente oggi abbiamo dei
principati molto più concentrati oggi la
scienza ci dice esattamente cosa c'è
all'interno di quella pianta e ci
permette di concentrare in maniera tale
per cui attraverso delle forme che sono
magari delle pastiglie delle capsule
l'assumiamo regolarmente
non dimentichiamoci che oggi più che mai
amo ragionare in termini di coltivazione
sostenibile fa o dice che coltivazione
sostenibile a qualcosa che deve dare
ovviamente valore aggiunto ma grande
attenzione alle nostre risorse acqua i
territori e grande attenzione al fatto
che le persone che ci lavorano devono
essere molto considerate molto più di
una volta è già stata tenente ovviamente
all'ambiente questo in perfetta
trasparenza
quello che è successo durante il lock
down
credo che tutti insomma l'abbiano
trovato chi aveva la fortuna di avere un
orto un giardino l'ha vissuto in maniera
molto molto forte molto intensa molto
piacevole
ci avevano terrazza l'ha trasformata in
un giardino pensile ovviamente ma chi
aveva un davanzale addirittura si è
messo sui pomodori in pomodori e
l'insalata perché comunque al centro
c'era in ogni caso qualcosa che era
naturale dopodiché come vedete questo
sono delle piccole serre
minuscole con delle luci artificiali
sono state vendute anche questo su
amazon le trovavate e servivano
praticamente a stressare la pianta per
farla crescere meglio quindi anche a
casa nostra abbiamo fatto quella
sperimentazione che oggi si cerca perché
ho la pianta al centro e voglio che
questa pianta che è ricchissima di
principi attivi me ne dia ancora di più
quindi abbiamo praticamente anticipato
comunque abbiamo seguito quel trend che
ha il trend sostanzialmente delle
culture che sono controllate che non
sono quelle su campo ovviamente che oggi
purtroppo il clima gli sbalzi di peso ma
levi clima basta pensare quello successo
qui vicino c'è voglio dire in un secondo
mi trova una coltivazione distrutta
quando parliamo di coltivazioni in
all'interno di strutture pensiamo sempre
alle vertical farm almeno io la penso
regolarmente vertical farm che esistono
da tempo in questo caso sono
coltivazioni aero poli che questi hanno
dei vantaggi enormi risparmio il 95 per
cento dell'acqua risparmio il 90 per
cento del terreno o 0 pesticidi perché
solo all'interno di una camera bianca
non ho bisogno di niente o zero
emissioni derivanti dai trasporti quando
quando ovviamente le tengo vicino e lo
posso fare
inoltre
usiamo dei capannoni vecchi usati che
non abbiamo e non sappiamo dove metterli
e utilizziamo energie rinnovabili a
tutto questa che in pratica è la parte
sostenibile attacchiamo una forma
digitale fortissima quindi proprio il
nostro binario la parte gita lei
l'intelligenza artificiale che c'è
all'interno perché ha una intelligenza
artificiale gestita ovviamente da forti
ricercatori che però ti permette di
capire esattamente la pianta che punto è
e posso fare a coltivare delle insalate
sono istallate croccanti e gradevole
saporite addirittura riescono lavarle
perché non ho bisogno
banalmente per il basilico se voglio
fare del pesto deve essere croccantino e
deve avere una componente aromatica
decisa se voi toccate questo basilico e
non vi lavate le mani per mezza giornata
sapete da basilico a pazzesco quello che
si può ottenere
torniamo però al mondo diciamo del
farmaco dell'integratore è questa la
conoscete la cannabis dove l'uso
ovviamente e soprattutto sul lato destro
quello farmaceutico dove li ci vuole
veramente un contenuto di si chiama
tetraidrocannabinolo che è una sostanza
che un'azione fortemente anti anti
dolorifica ma fortemente anti dolorifica
oggi le persone che hanno patologie
particolari vengono in farmacia si
preparano delle tisane o si preparano
degli oli usano delle gocce per
sostituire alcuni farmaci che magari
sono addirittura inefficaci immaginateli
mesi all'interno di queste serre dove io
ho bisogno sempre di un contenuto
elevato di tetraidrocannabinolo
si può fare assolutamente quindi
garantiscono efficacia nel tempo
e questo invece torniamo nell'ambito
dell'alimento torniamo nell'ambito
dell'integratore quello è chiaramente un
cavolfiore e cavoli sono come sapete
tutti è un è un cibo che contiene delle
sostanze antiossidanti molto forti in
america non segna anche uomo sono magica
voce ore perché il cavolfiore ti dà del
somma degli effetti sulla sulla
situazione sono antiossidanti sono
antinfiammatori
tanto è vero che una serie di aziende
italiane bravissime mandano in in
in stati negli stati uniti tonnellate e
tonnellate di gnocchi al cauliflower che
ha un percorso stranissimo però mangiano
i nostri sono buonissime noi siamo bravi
ma perchè perchè ripeto a principi
attivi
però se pensate bene quando io pianto
questo cavolfiore nei primi giorni viene
fuori una specie di fogliolina questo si
chiama mike rodrigues che ha un nome
abbastanza conosciuto lo trovate online
sicuramente il microwave contiene dalle
due alle tre volte i principi attivi che
contiene il cavolfiore premetto quando
lo mettete sulla vostra tavola contiene
poco è passato troppo tempo questo
michael se lo metto all'interno di una
tenuta coltivazione e diciamo aero
pollica in sarà verticale può arrivare
fino a 10 12 volte il contenuto in
principi attivi quindi potete immaginare
quale può essere l'esplosione di questo
prodotto naturale coltivato nella
maniera corretta
e chiaro che detto questo mi mi vien da
pensare ad einstein quella volta che ha
detto che voi cercate qualcosa
cercatelo nella natura cioè la natura ci
sa già tutto
e facciamolo nostro facciamo nostro e
attraverso le nostre riflessioni
attraverso la ricerca che faremo che
faranno tutti cerchiamo di trarne il
maggior vantaggio per noi stessi e per
le cose cui vogliamo più bene le persone
il nostro pianeta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]